the the idea of elevating if you like
people who may or may not have suffered
real disadvantage or been sidelined to a
sort of caste system and with
intersectionality you can add on to it
if you have other characteristics bowls
over the central idea of Western freedom
which is that all a worthy of dignity
and of standing because a higher
authority says they are but we mock that
idea completely we haven't found a
substitute for valuing one another
that's workable I think we have actually
the substitute is very simple if we
believe in not discriminating against
people in not in the way that you
defined it earlier but in a negative way
if we believe that people should be
treated equally and give an equal
opportunity based on their skills and
merit and talents that is a perfect
solution and what we now have is because
we've elevated certain groups to above
that mean above that median point we now
have a society where we promote certain
people ahead of others we have what
supposedly is called positive
discrimination I don't think any
discrimination can be positive in that
way
so actually the solution is there but
the reality is that as Douglas Murray
says some people enjoy the
overcorrection some people enjoy their
overcorrection and the power that comes
with it and the ability to shut down
anyone and to go well speaking as an
immigrant you're not allowed to say that
speaking as or whatever you're not
allowed to say that that's power in a
society that tries to debate ideas that
is tremendous power and people don't
want to give that up and they don't want
to give that up and I think that's a big
part of why this is happening and the
other thing is of course this whole
ideology of victimhood its weaponized
empathy its weaponized our empathy I'm
using your empathy against you because
if I say well look as a bla bla bla
I've been oppressed for 50 years you
empathize with that right as a human
being you naturally empathize so
anything I then tack onto that I've been
discriminated
therefore we must now overturn
capitalism it's harder to argue against
against simply the slogan we must
overturn capitalism
so it's weaponized empathy and that's
why it's become so powerful and so
corrosive because it's very difficult to
argue against excuse me when people
project this former oppression that
their victimhood and there is
discrimination society people some
people are racist some people are
bigoted and there are groups which have
been marginalized s directly and we are
now at a point where largely we've
addressed many of those issues but the
industries that they have created around
those Korea feminism Korea whatever else
it is those people are never going to be
covered up if you've got a successful
career as a TV feminist you're not gonna
give it up you know you're not gonna go
oh look the gender pay gap is pretty
much closed and in fact the women under
40 are out earning men you're not gonna
you're not gonna want to hear that
you're not gonna want to spread that you
also have your status in your power
derive from being a victim yeah you have
I try to be a vector to remind of it you
must remain a victim yeah you just want
to victimhood resolved absolutely why
would you want to give up your power
yeah no one wants to you